nice to see you again nice to see you
you know this is the film that we've
been waiting for to see your performance
deep breath
it's happening this is the moment right
it's happening first time with an
audience so that'll be fun i know how
how does it feel to see yourself
transform into
this incredible tammy thing
well um it's surreal experience i mean
i've wanted to make the film for almost
a decade so to be here tonight at the
premiere with an audiences
shocking
um
and i hope we've made something that
will inspire
an audience to look at maybe someone who
may think differently than them and
understand that everyone's deserving of
love and god's grace and acceptance and
you sing
i mean i can't imagine all the work you
did to make that voice happen to get
that voice
to hear yourself as tammy faye how does
that feel
it's i mean it's just the strangest
thing but i kind of like hear her voice
in my head all the time really
i really became obsessed with her and i
watched all the videos and um
oh yeah i think i've watched every
single thing that had been filmed on her
everything on youtube i watched all of
youtube all of youtube uh yeah i just i
became obsessed so i hear it all the
time so there's it's just kind of like
yeah that's uh that's normal now when
you looked at yourself in the mirror
did you take a second to kind of see
that
well
i took four hours to see that because it
was a long process but the wonderful
thing about the process is that it was a
long runway before takeoff each day so i
had a plenty of time to work on the
character to think about her voice to
think about where she was coming from in
the scenes and
it was very helpful now there's a lot of
buzz for you
and it's all a lot of buzz for benedict
cumberbatch i'm curious have you guys
never worked together
i know what is up why why is that i
don't know benny
we're gonna make it happen you guys
gotta work together i know it's funny
because in 2011 we both had movies that
were coming out we kind of we like
became friends at that time and i was
like showing them around l.a
so yeah we absolutely have to work
together congratulations congratulations
to all of you so thank you for chatting
with us thank you very much